[Música]
y es el momento de que nuestro compañero
Jorge Hurtado nos traiga toda la
información económica Jorge bienvenido
creo que vamos a empezar aquí en América
Latina porque el producto interno bruto
de México subió un 3% anual en el año
2022 Así lo dijo el Instituto Nacional
de estadísticas y geografía Inegi de
México y también esa cifra va en
concordancia con lo que habían
pronosticado ya también el gobierno y el
sector privado de ese país la economía
mexicana avanzó gracias al incremento de
la industria que fue de un 3,2% el
sector agropecuario que aportó otro 3% y
los servicios que dejaron 2,7% hay que
recordar que este aumento llega luego de
un crecimiento del 4,8% en 2021 y la
histórica contracción del 8,2% de 2020
justo cuando la pandemia golpeó en
términos trimestrales el pib del cuarto
trimestre creció un 3,5% interanual
frente al mismo periodo del 2021 el
organismo siempre publica esta
estimación del producto interno bruto
antes de revelar el dato definitivo al
próximo 24 de febrero es importante
decir que pese al aumento el pib de
México es uno de los más rezagados de
latinoamérica en la recuperación
postpandemia Bueno pues hablando de
recuperación post pandemia vamos a
hablar de mi País España porque el
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez ha ligado ha
hablado con los agentes sociales
principalmente con los sindicatos para
subir de nuevo el salario mínimo lo
subió al 8% y ahora se va a Ubicar en
1080 euros mensuales así lo anunció el
presidente de gobierno Pedro Sánchez
quien aumentó el salario pese a la
oposición del sector privado se trata
del cuarto aumento al salario mínimo
desde el 2020 y una subida total
acumulada del
47%. el acuerdo que beneficiará casi dos
millones y medio de trabajadores se fue
firmado tras dos reuniones celebradas el
martes entre los representantes del
Ministerio del trabajo y los sindicatos
la inflación que afecta a la mayoría de
países del Mundo significa una carga
para la familia españolas que vieron Un
aumento promedio del 8,4% por el alza de
los alimentos y también las facturas
energéticas antes El Ejecutivo aumentó
un 8,5 las pensiones y mejoró el sueldo
de los trabajadores públicos para
intentar contrarrestar la inflación
España actualmente es el segundo país de
la ocde que más ha subido el salario
mínimo desde el año 2018
seguimos con consecuencias ahora Jorge
de la de desaceleración económica porque
PayPal es una más de las tecnológicas
que dice que va a despedir a parte de su
plantilla a dos mil personas exactamente
los recortes afectarán alrededor del 7%
de la planilla se producirán en las
próximas semanas la empresa busca
rentabilidades del año pasado cuando se
embarcó en una iniciativa de reducción
de costos que supondría un ahorro de
1300 millones de dólares este año la
medida de PayPal se produce también en
un contexto de inflación que está
afectando el poder adquisitivo de los
consumidores mientras crecen de esta
recesión global las acciones de la
empresa que perdieron cerca del 60% de
su valor el año pasado subieron
alrededor del 2% en las operaciones tras
la noticia la industria tecnológica
lideró los recortes de empleo en 2022
con un total de más de 97 mil puestos en
todo el sector pues Jorge nos vamos
ahora a las farmacéuticas vamos a hablar
de pfizer una de las empresas de la que
más hemos hablado en estos últimos años
que hoy presentó su informe de
resultados bueno las acciones de pfizer
sufrieron en enero su mayor caída
mensual desde el año 2009 esto por el
temor de los inversores sobre el futuro
del modelo de negocio de la compañía la
acción cayó un 15% este mes borrando 43
mil millones de dólares en valor de
Mercado en su informe de resultados
pfizer presentó unas perspectivas de
ventas más débiles de lo estimado para
su vacuna y la píldora contra el Kobe 19
y sus acciones fluctuaron durante la
jornada la vacuna desarrollada y
producida por pfizer y un Tech ayudaron
al mundo a superar la pandemia y a la
farmacéutica también a lograr los
mayores beneficios de su historia unos
31.372 millones de dólares solamente en
2022 la vacuna logra sus mayores
ingresos en Europa mientras que la
píldora su principal mercado es Estados
Unidos pfizer es dependiente de esta
vacuna y la píldora contra el covid y
ahora que la pandemia remite entre los
analistas hay dudas sobre la evolución
de su negocio la empresa admitió que sus
ingresos podrían caer entre un 29% y un
33% este año interesante dato Jorge Dino
sabrá qué cifrar nos traes hoy 2
millones de empleos formales eso generó
Brasil en 2022 eso es un 26,6% menos que
los creados en 2021 según los datos
divulgados por el registro general de
empleados y desempleados ese registro es
elaborado por el Ministerio del trabajo
y cerramos con Los indicadores de las
principales bolsas empezamos en Wall
Street que cerró su mejor enero en años
y el nasdaq el que reúne las
tecnológicas subió un 10,7% mensual en
Europa el índice stock 600 cayó debido a
que los inversores se preparan ya para
una nueva Ronda de subidas de los tipos
de interés de los parte de los
principales bancos centrales del mundo y
en América Latina la bolsa de valores de
Sao Paulo subió un 1,3% con lo que el
índice de referencia del mayor mercado
latinoamericano acumuló una apreciación
del 3,37% en todo el mes de enero pues
Jorge muchas gracias por este
completísimo reporte económico te invito
a que sigas con nosotros en directo
[Música]